one of the pro-trans crowd's favorite
talking points is that rates of regret
and de-transition are low
they will often say that the rate of
detransition is one percent maybe two
percent but it turns out that talking
point is not true a new study on a
sample of about 1 000 transitioners has
found a detransition rate of nearly 30
percent hat tip to Megan McArdle from
The Washington Post for calling
attention to this study it is called the
continuation of gender affirming
hormones among transgender adolescents
and adults study was published in the
journal of clinical endocrinology and
metabolism and it found that the
four-year trans hormone continuation
rate was just 70.2 percent that's a far
cry from the 98 99 statistic that the
trans activists promote